في السعوديه اربعه اعوام مرت على اطلاق
برنامج تطوير صناعه الوطنيه والخدمات
اللوجستيه في السعوديه ندلب سنوات حقق من
خلالها البرنامج اجمالي استثمارات يصل الى
456 مليار ريال في قطاعاته الاربعه في ظل
نمو ملحوظ لاجمال الصادرات السعوديه غير
النفطيه التي وصلت الى 435 مليار ريال
وبزياده تقدر بنحو 38% في العام الماضي
مقارنه ب 2021 وفي سياق تركيز ادلب على
محور الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه قامت الهيئه
السعوديه للمدن الصناعيه مدن بتقييم مئه
مصنع وتقديم خارطه طريق لتبني التقنيات
الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه وتحفيز تبني
التقنيات الاساسيه والمتقدمه لدى 37 مشاه
انضموا الي هنا في الاستديو سليمان
المزروع رئيس التنفيذي لبرنامج التطوير
الصناعه الوطنيه والخدمات اللوجستيه ادلب
حياك الله سعي المهندس شكرا اخوي نايف
الاسطافه الله يحييك في ظل مشهد تحول
وتغير كبير على
مستوى رؤيه 2030 انتصف الطريق الان ما
الذي تحقق حتى الان في ندلب منذ انطلاق
البرنامج وحتى اليوم فيما يخص التحول على
مستوى القطاعات الاربعه الصناعه التعدين
الخدمات اللوجستيه ان شاء الله
في الحقيقه تسمح لي قبل ما ابدا في قطاعات
البرنامج اتكلم كيف رؤيه المملكه 2030
قاعد تحقق هذه الانجازات اللي تشوفها وش
الاساسيات اللي بنيت عليها اهم ثلاثه
اساسيات ممكن نطرحها لساعدتنا الوصول لهذه
الانجازات اللي نشوفها اولها ايمان قياده
الملهمه بابنائه وبناتها لتحقيق هذه
الطموحات العاليه اثنين شموليتها شموليه
هذه الرؤيه لتغطيه جميع احتياجات المواطن
من اسكان تنميه بشريه مصادر نمو وغيرها من
احتياجات المواطن وكذلك الشراكه مع القطاع
الخاص القطاع العام القطاع غير ربحي
المواطن المواطن المقيم جميع من يستطيع
المشاركه في هذه 2030 يقدر يشارك فيها
والحمد لله
اخر نقطه وهي طموحات المملكه هي صحيح
للسعوديين لكنها تشارك في المجتمع الدولي
وجميع طموحاته نتكلم عن سد ثغرات سلاسل
الامداد ربط القارات تقديم صناعات معرفيه
تطور الانسان والمجتمع العالمي فهذا ما
جعلها رؤيه مباركه للسعدين والعالم الجميع
حنا في برنامج تطوير صناعه والوطنيه او
الخدمات ادلب معنيين بتنويع مصادر النمو
في اربع قطاعات حيويه صناعه وتعديل
والطاقه والخدمات اللوجستيه
نطمح باذن الله نكون قوه صناعيه رائده
ومنصه لاجتي عالميه باذن الله في 20
الحديث دائما عن العوائد الاقتصاديه حتى
الان سواء اللي جات بشكل مباشر او التي
جاءت بشكل غير مباشر يعني على على
البرنامج وعلى هذه القطاعات الاربعه اللي
موجوده فيه وكمان ايضا في محورين ارتكاز
ايضا في في البرنامج
بلا شك البرنامج برنامج اقتصادي ومقاييسه
مؤشراته هي اقتصاديه ايضا لدينا اول مؤشر
وهو الناتج المحلي المملكه حققت الحمد لله
في 2022
الاعلى نموا من خلال مجموعه العشرين وهذا
يعتبر رقم عالي من الاسرع نمون على مستوى
العالم ومستوى مجموعه العشرين
الصادرات الغير نفطيه حققنا اكثر من 435
مليار وهو يتضاعف عن ما كنا عليه قبل رؤيه
قبل رؤيه تقريبا في عام 2016 تقريبا 242
الان نتكلم عن 435
صناعه يعني صناعات جديده وصادرات غير
نفطيه جديده دخلت في المزيج صادرات غير
نفطيه الحمد لله كذلك الاستثمارات حققنا
ما يقارب ال500 مليار استثمارات منذ بدايه
البرنامج وهذا الرقم عالي جدا لكن يدل على
زياده جاذبيه هذه القطاعات
للمستثمرين سواء في الصناعه الطاقه في
التعديل او الخدمات القطاعات الاربعه
باجيها بس خلني اتكلم على اول قطعين اللي
هي الطاقه والتعديل خلينا نبدا فيها هي من
القطاعات الاربعه التنفيذيه وش اللي تحقق
فيها والملفت ايضا كذلك في هذا القطاعين
قطاع الطاقه هو قطاع ريادي على مستوى
المملكه والعالم بقياده سمو وزير الطاقه
عراب الطاقه ودبلوماسية اذا بركز على
نقطتين التقرير مليء بالانجازات لكن
نقطتين مهمتين اولها تحول للطاقه المتجدده
عندنا في 2022 الحمد لله اكثر من ترسيه
اكثر من اربع مشاريع وطرح اكثر من خمس
مشاريع نتكلم عن مجمل 21 مليار ريال من
المشاريع للطاقه المتجدده كذلك التوطين
صناعات المرتبطه بالنفط الغاز وصلنا الى
اكثر من 63% وهذا رقم عالي جدا في مثل هذه
الصناعات الصعبه وتوطينها يحتاج الى جهود
الحمد لله بجهود الجهات التنفيذيه وشراكه
خلاص تم تحقيقها
في ايضا قطاع الصناعه والخدمات اللوجستيه
شهدت كانت نقله نوعيه كبيره عندما تمت
الاعلان عن الاستراتيجيات الوطنيه
المرتبطه فيها واللي تحققت في 2022
بالاضافه ايضا كذلك
الثوره يمكن الصناعيه الرابعه لليوم
الحديث ماذا عنها وش اللي يتحقق فيها حتى
الان بالنسبه للصناعه حنا نقيسها استثناء
نستثمر ونصنع ونصدر نقيس الاستثمارات كميه
الاستثمارات اللي تصب في هذا القطاع نشوف
كم عدد المصانع اللي يزداد في مديرنا
الصناعيه كبير فيها صراحه صحيح وصلنا الى
عشره الاف500 مصنع هذا الرقم
يعادل 50% بما تم قبل الرؤيه لمده اربعين
سنه يعني لك من بدايه الصناعه في المملكه
1975 الى 2016 تقريبا 7,200 مصنع
في وقت رؤيه المملكه وصلنا الى 10,500 في
المئه من حققناه في 40 سنه حققناه في ست
سنوات او سبع سنوات اللي في رؤيه المملكه
20 30 فالممكنات الاضافيه العمل الاضافي
اللي صار من خلال رؤيه المملكه 20 30
ومبادراتها بدينا نشوف
رده على الاستثمارات واعلى المصانع اخر
شيء طبعا احنا نقيسها من خلال ما نراه من
صندوق التنميه الصناعي الاقراض اللي يصير
تقريبا اكثر من 14 مليار في 22 وهذا يدل
على زياده في عام واحد في عام واحد اكثر
من 14 مليار كذلك من ناحيه تصدير شفنا
التسهيلات الائتمانيه اللي قدمها بنك
التصدير واستيراد واللي هي تقريبا اكثر من
14 بوينت 14.6 مليار من التسهيلات
التامينيه اللي صارت في
الصادرات السعوديه الغير نفطيه طبعا
وارتباط او الخدمات اللوجستيه ايضا
الخدمات اللجديه والتعدين يعتبرون من
القطاعات الواعده في المملكه اللي بدات مع
رؤيه المملكه 2030 تاخذ اهتمام الكبير من
القياده الملهمه اول باكلم شوي عن
اللاجستيه وكذلك عن التعدين القطاع
اللوجستي شفناه ست منصات لجستيه في
الموانع جديده منطقه لوجستيه خاصه في مطار
الملك خالد جابت لنا استثمارات مثل ابل في
مطار في منطقه اللوجستيه في مطار الملك
خالد قفزنا اكثر من 17 مرتبه في مؤشر صادر
من البنك الدولي لاداء الخدمات اللوجستيه
كذلك راينا زياده في
اعاده تصدير والمسافنه بارقام قياسيه
موجوده في
التقرير لمن اراد الاستيازه فيها ارقام
اللوجستيه بدينا نشوف بدايه نجاحاتها في
20 22 الحمد لله من ناحيه التعدين حقيقه
كذلك واحد القطاعات الواعده واللي بدا مع
رؤيه المملكه 2030 بعد استراتيجيته وتنظيم
القطاع
بالاستثمار فيه شفناه ايرادات غير نفطيه
هي الاعلى على مستوى تاريخ القطاع تقريبا
اكثر من 95% من محققه في 21 حققها في 22
شفنا رخصتين استكشاف رخصه الاستكشاف شراكه
مع القطاع الخاص لاستكشاف الخناقيه ومن
الدمار وخمسه وعشرين بالم ئه تم الحمد لله
استكشافها من الدر العربي اللي في عائد
كثير على الاقتصاد السعودي
المهندس سليمان المزروع رئيس التنفيذي
لبرنامج تطوير الصناعه الوطنيه والخدمات
اللوجستيه شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات